legend al-hadul had been a prominent
activist for years
demanding more rights for women in saudi
arabia
the un rights groups have been demanding
her release from a saudi prison
she'd been arrested in 2018 with other
activists
but instead saudi media are reporting
that a court sentence had lured
to five years and eight months in prison
she was found guilty on charges
including agitating for change
and mounting a campaign against the
saudi royal family
she had campaigned against a ban on
women driving
a ban that was lifted the same year but
the kingdom
continues to deny that she was arrested
for this reason
her brother says her family will appeal
the verdict it's showing that there is
no
way we can get justice from
a sham trial if we can put it that way
um
it can clearly show that the the court
in the trial from day one has been
politically motivated the saudi court
suspended two years and 10 months of her
sentence
and many say this could have been to
avoid a confrontation
with u.s president-elect joe biden he'd
been openly critical of the kingdom's
human rights records
and the transition's team security
advisor tweeted the sentencing
was unjust and troubling the judge's
verdict today
gave her credit for time already served
and so if you do all the math
um there's a good chance that she might
be out um
out of prison in about two months and
that that's not a coincidence because i
think the incoming byte administration
really is weighing heavily on the
decision of the
saudi authorities on this topic hadlow's
family says last year
saudi authorities offered to release her
but only if she gave testimony
denying that she'd been tortured and
sexually harassed
the saudi courts say there was no
evidence of this
the family say the torture was designed
as a brutal way to break her
but she won't be broken laura about a
manly al jazeera